now amid a growing backlash the Florida
school resource officer who arrested two
six-year-olds at their Orlando school
has been fired officer Dennis Turner
Turner was terminated yesterday battery
charges against the children have also
been dropped Manuel Bojorquez reports
from the police headquarters in Orlando
on behalf of myself and the entire
Orlando Police Department I apologize to
the children involved and their families
Orlando police chief Orlando rolanse
says he had no choice but to fire
reserve officer Dennis Turner
after Turner arrested two six-year-olds
at their school last Thursday we could
not fathom the idea of a six-year-old
being put in the back of a police car
Turner arrested kaya roll after she
allegedly kicked a staff member during a
tantrum rolls grandmother said the
outburst was likely a result of the
child's sleep apnea it was really and
truly an injustice on her Turner also
arrested an unidentified student in a
separate incident and sent both children
to a juvenile detention center the
criminal process ends here Florida State
Attorney aramis Ayala said her office
would not prosecute the six year olds I
refuse to knowingly play any role in the
school to Prison Pipeline at any age but
juvenile arrests in Florida are not
unheard of last fiscal year nearly three
thousand children falling between the
ages of 5 and 12 were arrested
now kaya roll is ready for a return to
normal Orlando's police chief says he
also sent a letter to all officers on
Friday reminding them of the
department's policy which is to have a
supervisor sign off on the arrest of
anyone under 12 gale that story is still
so hard to believe we thank you very
much Manuel